künstliche intelligenz hat jetzt eine
der großen fragen der menschheit gelöst
an diesem problem beißen sich fachleute
aus der gesamten welt seit einem halben
jahrhundert die zähne aus die
dreidimensionale struktur von proteinen
ohne sie können wir nicht leben und
läuft mit ihnen etwas falsch verursachen
sie schlimme krankheiten die
google-tochter dick meint will diesen
heiligen gral der biologie mit ihrem
programm alpha von zwei geknackt haben
klicks umsatz im future gibt es dreimal
pro woche spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocken nur so verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen und vielen
dank für diesen coolen themen
vorschlagen den uns ernst über unsere
telegate gruppe klicks um science in
future geschickt hat den link dazu
findet ihr hier dort könnte er auch
mitdiskutieren diesmal sind es nicht nur
die medien die von einem zitat
durchbruch berichten auf viele
forschende sind baff darüber was die
britische tochterfirma von google die
meint da jetzt geschafft hat die rede
ist von lernenden algorithmen eine
künstliche intelligenz in der lage dazu
ist etwas voraus zu sagen was die
fachwelt trotz jahrzehntelanger
forschung noch immer nicht geschafft hat
der name des programms alpha von zwei
die algorithmen sagen voraus wie sich
ein protein genau falten wird und dafür
müssen sie einzig und allein den mix aus
aminosäuren kennen aus dem die proteine
bestehen und an dieser stelle muss man
echt mal festhalten das ist vor allem
für die mikrobiologin und mikrobiologen
dieser welt ein echter durchbruch ja
vielleicht sogar etwas wie der heilige
gral aber nicht nur die
grundlagenforschung wird durch dieses
ergebnis profitieren sondern auch die
pharmazeutische und medizinische
forschung wir stehen vor meilensteinen
der medizin kurz mal zur erklärung
proteine sind nichts anderes als riesige
molekülketten und diese müssen damit sie
funktionieren richtig gefaltet sein
ansonsten passiert nichts oder das
falsche es reicht also hier nicht nur
die richtige chemische formel zu kennen
das ergebnis muss auch richtig
angeordnet sein wenn wir schnell und
zuverlässig aus einer bekannten
aminosäuren sequenz auf die struktur
eines proteins schließen können ließen
sich damit menschenleben retten ganz
aktuell zeigt uns dass unser kampf gegen
die korona pandemie und zwar aus dem
einen grund saß kopf zwei hat auf seiner
oberfläche ein bestimmtes protein und
seine 3 d
struktur macht das virus erst so
erfolgreich heißt also im klartext wer
diese 3d struktur kennt und versteht und
somit auch die art und weise wie sie
funktioniert kann sie auch bekämpfen das
alles ging bislang nur in teuer langsam
und aufwendig die fachleute müssen dazu
auf experimentelle verfahren zu
begreifen wie beispielsweise die
kristall strukturanalyse mit
röntgenstrahlung zu den neuen
erkenntnissen der künstlichen
intelligenz alpha von zwei sagt gunnar
schröder von der jülicher
forschungsgruppe computational
strukturbiologie auf welt.de
das schnell wachsende gebiet der
personalisierten medizin könnte damit
sogar zur personalisierten molekularen
medizin werden weil der wirkstoffe und
therapie in zukunft auf die persönlichen
proteinstrukturen eines einzigen
patienten zuschneiden
heißt also im klartext dass die neuen
erkenntnisse spannender ansatzpunkte für
neue therapien und medikamente liefern
könnten wie schon erwähnt sind
proteinstrukturen auch im kampf gegen
die aktuelle pandemie ein wichtiger
schlüssel und das alpha volk
forschungsteam weiß darum die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
haben bereits ihre künstliche
intelligenz dazu eingesetzt um die
struktur mehrerer viraler proteine von
saas koch 2 zu entschlüsseln
im visier standen dabei unter anderem
die proteine mit der bezeichnung orf 8
und orf 3 a die von mutationen
betroffenen proteine sind die bausteine
unseres lebens und sie sind wichtig für
alle möglichen funktionen unseres
körpers entscheidend hierbei ihre
dreidimensionale struktur proteine
selbst bestehen aus einer kette von
aminosäuren und deren abfolge ergibt
sich aus der genetische bauanleitung die
faltung der aminosäuren kette dagegen
ist alles andere als vorhersehbar
dahinter stecken tatsächlich zahlreiche
faktoren dazu der max planck
wissenschaftler jürgen kock obwohl diese
struktur eindeutig durch die gesetze der
physik vorgegeben ist ist deren
berechnung ausgehend von den
grundlegenden formen der quantenmechanik
als aussichtslos anzusehen denn dazu
benötigte rechenaufwand wäre gigantisch
und so kommt es dass trotz intensiver
forschung bislang nur von rund einem
prozent der proteine die 3d struktur
bekannt ist eine art heiliger gral also
ein nahezu und schlüssel bares geheimnis
die alles entscheidende frage die
forschende weltweit bereits seit rund 50
jahren umtreibt lässt sich an
der aminosäuren abfolge eine vorhersage
darüber treffen wie die finale gestalt
eines proteins aussehen wird jetzt ein
möglicher durchbruch gibt meint dass ki
forschungszentrum von google hat nämlich
ein lernfähiges system geschaffen das
von den fachleuten darauf trainiert
wurde gesetzmäßigkeiten in der
proteinfaltung zu erkennen es handelt
sich um ein neuronales netzwerk und
trainiert wurde es mithilfe 170.000
bekannten proteinstrukturen mit seiner
hilfe ist die meint beim sogenannten
kast wettbewerb als klarer sieger
hervorgegangen die abkürzung steht für
critical assessment of protein structure
prediction und die aufgabe für die
teilnehmenden forschungsgruppen besteht
darin die faltung von proteinen
vorherzusagen und zwar auf basis der
aminosäuren sequenzen für proteine
am ende werden die vorhergesagten
positionen dann mit den ergebnissen aus
experimentellen analysen verglichen und
hierbei liefert die die pmone calwer
folgt in der zweiten version tatsächlich
ziemlich herausragend ab dem ki system
gelang es die struktur von 70 der
insgesamt 100 zu lösenden protein
abfolgen vorherzusagen und zwar mit
hoher präzision insgesamt 100 punkte
waren bei diesem sogenannten global
diesen test gdp zu erreichen dieser
schlüssel auf wie nah die
prognostizierten positionen der protein
komponenten ihrer tatsächlichen position
sind durchschnittlich erreichte alter
von 22 und 90,4 punkte und selbst bei
den strukturen die in der fachwelt als
kompliziert zu knacken eingestuft wurden
erreicht denn das ki system 85 punkte
vorläufer kamen wir bisher nur auf einen
bruchteil der punkte und damit steht
fest die künstliche intelligenz von deep
meint ist ganz weit vorne und das mit
abstand
die erreichte präzision wird
normalerweise nur bei experimentellen
analysen erreicht die teilweise
jahrelange arbeit in anspruch nehmen
wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen
weltweit sind begeistert so sagt der us
biologe und gründer des kaspar herbst
rollt über alpha pult das ist die erste
anwendung künstlicher intelligenz die
ein ernsthaftes problem gelöst hat auch
die wissenschaftler in janet konnten vom
european bioinformatics institute die
seit 50 jahren zu der faltung von
proteinen forscht ist beeindruckt ich
dachte nicht dass dieses problem zu
meinen lebzeiten noch gelöst wird das
ist eine
dieser fortschritt ähnlich begeistert
ist auch der molekular biologe john
krasinski war das ist ein durchbruch es
gibt natürlich einschränkungen und
aspekte die verbessert werden müssen
bevor das problem der struktur
vorhersage endgültig gelöst ist aber die
genauigkeit und erfolgsrate von alpha
fund ist beispiellos
die fachwelt wartet jetzt gespannt auf
die veröffentlichung der ergebnisse die
im nachgang zum wettbewerb erfolgen soll
auch der quellcode des programms und die
rohdaten sollen veröffentlicht werden
gibt meint selbst wies darauf hin dass
ihr ki system noch in der entwicklung
steckt wie bei jeder wissenschaftlichen
forschung gibt es noch offene fragen es
gibt noch viel zu lernen darunter wie
proteine komplexe bilden wie sie mit dna
rna oder kleinen molekülen interagieren
und wie wir die präzise position aller
aminosäuren seitenketten bestimmen
können zum ersten mal fiel alpha folgt
in der version 1 auf als es bei kassen
geben rosetta die bis dato
erfolgreichste auf dem gebiet gewarnt
bereits da ging ein erdbeben durch die
wissenschaftsgemeinde durchbruch bei ki
dieb meint revolutioniert die medizin
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren
diesen kanal giggs umsatz im future bis
dann bleibt dran